I lost my country my job my paper my
family my house everything really it's
the most horrible year of my life
John Dunda has been living in Berlin for
a year now in exile in Turkey he was
chief editor of jammu yet his articles
criticizing the government resulted in
criminal charges brought by president
edwin himself Dena spent time in custody
and was put on trial but when the chance
arose he left for Germany in a way I
carried my myself to Germany and I'm
kind of living in a cell here don't
going out too much because of the
security reasons and concentrating
mainly on the the struggle and
trying to support my friends in jail
from his Berlin office sundar is
following the chimoree at trial in
Istanbul many other employees of the
newspaper face the same terrorism
charges Jindal says he is close friends
with most of them I couldn't get the
president of our Foundation and at the
same time my lawyer and he used to come
and visit me in jail and he took me out
and he's in jail now and cut yourself is
one of the most famous authors in Turkey
and I asked him to come to Emory and he
accepted it and just one thing later he
was arrested supporters of the Jim
harriet staff called the trial a farce
the state prosecutor argues that the
journalists editorial content supports
terrorist organizations president air
duan also sees it this way he says that
in his country no journalist is behind
bars simply for being a journalist
[Applause]